[APPLAUSE]
MITRA NATARAJ: So thank you,
Michelle, for joining us.
I'm Mitra.
For those of you
who don't know me,
I'm a business
manager in [INAUDIBLE]
Michelle is the CEO of Peanut.
And she she's also the founder.
And it's basically a
Tinder-style dating apps
for moms to meet other mothers.
The app launched
in Feb this year
and has had amazing traction.
So it's been picked
up in the press a lot.
So you might have seen
her mentioned there.
And we wanted to take
this opportunity for her
to come in because I know
a lot of Googlers talk
about starting their
own thing or starting
something outside of work.
And sometimes the inertia of
just being in your day job
can stop that.
So someone who's actually gone
from working for other people
to working for herself is
quite an interesting journey.
So Michelle also launched
Peanut on Android in October.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Yeah
MITRA NATARAJ:
Yeah, so finally we
can claim fame to it as
well, which is amazing.
So I'm going to do
a few questions,
but, really, please come.
Please have your own
questions prepared.
So we'll have loads of time
at the end for your questions
as well.
So I remember distinctly
when you first
talked to us about the idea.
So I know Michelle outside
of this particular thing.
We were at a wedding, and
she had her phone and a deck
on her phone.
And it was like, this
is my idea for an app
and what it was
going to be like.
I remember at that
point she was kind
of passing the phone around
the table, and a lot of people
were like, this is amazing.
And equally a lot of people were
like, isn't this like Mumsnet
and really challenging
about the idea.
So can you talk a
little bit about where
the idea came from, and then how
you got to that first investor
meeting and the challenges and
people's reactions to that?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Yeah,
so I started life actually
as a corporate
lawyer way back when.
That was my starting point.
I used to do a lot
of M&A. And I went
to work in-house for a
biotech company which
was, again very, very different
and not very me at all.
And one of the lawyers that
I used to work for called me
and me, you should
go meet this guy.
He's a new client of mine.
He needs someone to
go and work with him.
I think you'd be great.
I think you'll love it.
It's a dating web site.
I was, like, uh-hm, not really.
And this was back in 2010.
And dating was definitely
not what it is now.
And there was definitely a
feeling of like, mm, dating,
not sure--
maybe something your parents
did when they got divorced
or it just wasn't
like it is today.
And tech definitely
wasn't the kind of--
in London, it
definitely didn't have
the same feel and excitement
and buzz that it does now.
And I went to meet the founder.
He was a young guy
who was unusual.
And it was interesting.
I'd never really understood
it as a business.
And what I mostly
couldn't understand
is that there were 56 million
people using this product I'd
never heard of called Badoo.
MITRA NATARAJ: Has
anyone heard of Badoo?
Yeah?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: And I
met a few more people.
It was very exciting.
It was some crazy
rundown office in Soho.
And I decided I would do it.
So I became the lawyer there.
I'm very noisy.
I asked lots of questions--
under the guise of being
the lawyer, you're allowed--
and particularly was fascinated
by it was making money.
I wanted to
understand how people
were using the product,
what the journey was,
why they would pay
for certain things.
And then I was there for the
evolution from web to mobile.
So this was all back, like web.
I think the most adventurous
we had was [INAUDIBLE]..
And it was kind of
that transition.
And that was exciting,
really understanding
why people's behavior
was different,
why people were spending
differently, how long they
spent on web versus mobile--
all of these different
vantage points
that I'd never really
seen of a business before.
And it came to the
evolution of Tinder.
And Tinder came out.
And I remember my girlfriends
in the States talking about it
and me being like, what is it?
And it was a gray screen.
And I was desperate to see
and desperate to understand.
And that was really the
starting point of looking more--
less about legal and more about
being involved in the business.
I started working alongside
Andre as his kind of right hand
and became deputy CEO at Badoo.
And as part of that
was involved in Bumble,
which I'm very proud of
and was very exciting.
And I suppose it was
that whole journey.
And that was over the
course of five years--
wrapped up in 30 seconds--
that I decided that
I really wanted
to do something that-- a
product that I would use.
I wasn't dating in
my personal life.
And I really had
had this experience
when I became a mother
that I didn't really have
any girlfriends who had babies.
And I really wanted to just
take all of the learnings
that I had about connectivity
and apply it to women.
I also was really frustrated
by the products that
were out there for mothers.
Everything changed.
You go from using--
whether it is Snapchat-- at
the time, which was really,
really buzzing--
or Insta or Pinterest
or Deliveroo
or any of these amazing-- or
Uber-- any of these very slick,
cool products.
And then you become a mom,
and it was like, well,
where's my thing?
And everything felt like
it was very much aimed
at babies and kids and not
aimed at me as a woman.
And so I decided I would do it.
So I left Badoo in
January last year.
And it was absolutely
terrifying.
I loved my job.
And I loved what I did.
And I was very
proud of everything
that I did with Badoo
and with Bumble.
And so to make that move was--
well, you know.
I was very scared.
But I really wanted to do it.
And I believed in it.
And it wasn't just that I
wanted to do a product for me.
It's a huge business
opportunity.
Women are making 85% of
household decisions on spend,
and yet there was
just this huge gap.
And I really wanted
to address it.
So I left, did a
lot of consulting,
saved a lot of money because I
knew I would have to start the
build on my own.
And I went to one of
our friends' weddings
and was talking through it.
And one of our friends,
in particular--
who is now a very
avid supporter--
was like, I don't get it.
I don't think moms
really need this.
And I was, like,
how would you know?
You're not a mom.
But also, why?
And he was like, yeah,
but, this is Mumsnet.
I was like, absolutely not.
This is something
very, very different.
And I think at that time,
I had had my term sheet.
So I had just got a
term sheet from NEA.
And getting the term sheet,
it was a real whirlwind
because I don't think I
really fully appreciated
what that process was.
So I'd gone from--
probably through naivete--
I just was really ballsy and
had me in a deck and that's it.
MITRA NATARAJ: So
that's all you how had?
Did you commission someone
to do some research?
Or did you do your own research?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Me.
Yeah.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I had done it.
MITRA NATARAJ: OK.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I'd
just gone and researched
the market, had a look
at what had changed.
What was the size of the market?
What else was out there?
Doing those weird
competitor analyses,
speaking to women, so
many women everywhere--
on Facebook groups,
in real life,
everywhere-- asking them what
they did, what was their view.
Lots and lots of that
qualitative research.
MITRA NATARAJ: And was one
of the overwhelming things
that came from that
was that there was just
nothing on the market that
really targeted a woman who
was a modern person, basically?
It would seem to
be from the '80s.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Yeah, I think
that the overwhelming response
was we were using
products, or women
were using products
that were there
because that's what they had.
And there wasn't really anything
that had innovated forward.
And it was that moment
for me, where I was
like, why can it be me then?
Why can't I be the
one to change it?
And that is not to do down
any of the products that
were out there.
Mumsnet, BabyCenter,
What to Expect--
all of these amazing platforms
did something amazing
15 years ago, which is they gave
women a voice who are mothers.
And we didn't have it before.
So I would never
ever knock that.
It was just I was looking at
doing something different.
MITRA NATARAJ: So
you have this idea.
You have this deck.
How do you-- where
do you go from there?
Who were you shopping
it around to?
And how do you get your
first investors on board?
And what was that process like?
Especially since there
wasn't anything exactly
like what you were
describing on the market.
And you're going to
a lot of investors
who I'm assuming
don't understand
that particular psyche and
that particular loneliness that
comes from motherhood.
So how do you go through that
process of convincing them
that this is something
that there is a market for?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: That
part is challenging.
So in terms of how
do you identify?
It's very different-- or,
how I did it this time around
and how I would do
it going forward,
and if I were doing
it again, it's
very different to how
I did it completely
naively and inexperiencedly,
which is I spoke to everyone.
If someone said, I'll give you
an intro, I was like, great.
I'll take the intro.
And I was non-discriminatory
in who I spoke to.
And I suppose the upside
of that is I learned a lot.
So I learned when things--
what conversations
not to have, what
the difference between a late
stage and early stage fund is,
and, oh, when
someone says to you,
we're at the end of our fund.
But if you can hold
off until we're
at the beginning of our next
fund, what does that even mean?
All of basic things that just
were a complete mind field.
And this time I've been
much more targeted,
and I want to speak
to you because I
think you understand the
market or whatever it might be.
But I spoke to everyone,
and that is tough.
I shamelessly asked
for intros to people.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah,
well, you have to.
Yeah.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I'd have to.
And I asked friends, and
friends of friends, ,
and met I met NEA through
Whitney at Bumble.
And that was the kind
of starting point.
And from there, anyone I
spoke to, I would always
say at the end of it, thank
you so much for your time.
If you can think of
anyone else that you think
I should be speaking to--
and I always ended like that.
I don't think that's necessarily
the right way, by the way.
Do your own research,
and you can be--
MITRA NATARAJ: More targeted.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: More targeted,
because it's important for you,
too.
It's like a marriage, right?
You're getting into a
relationship with this person.
They're going to
be in your business
for the next foreseeable.
MITRA NATARAJ: So how did you
approach things differently
with your second round.
This is your seed funding
round that she just closed.
It was on the front
page of the "Times."
I don't know if
anyone else saw it.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Thanks.
MITRA NATARAJ: So,
yeah, that's fantastic.
So congratulations on that.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Thank you.
MITRA NATARAJ: So how did
you approach it differently?
Did you target
funds and say, I'm
going to go after you for your--
because I believe that
you'll understand this market
a little bit better?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: It
was obviously easier
because before I
was pre-product.
I was kind of
pre-team, actually.
Greg and I hadn't--
at the point I was starting
to speak to investors, Greg
and I hadn't decided
to work together.
He's my co-founder.
And so it was very, very early.
This time, obviously,
our product is out there.
We have metrics.
We have a team.
We can go out, and it's much
easier to speak to people.
And I was much more purposeful
about who I was speaking to
and why.
And so we have two joint
lead investors on this round.
And they both bring
something different
I'm really excited about.
Sweet Capital, who are
the founders of king.com,
so Candy Crush, which
was really exciting--
MITRA NATARAJ: That's amazing.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: --for me
from a product perspective
and their insight and their
understanding of women
spending time on Candy
Crush and all of those.
That was valuable
for me, and I really
was excited to
have them on board.
And the Female Founders Fund
in New York, obviously exciting
for me to have a female VC
with that kind of overview
and understanding of
the female market.
So I was very, very specific
about who we spoke to.
I also kept in contact
with people like Greycroft,
who I'd met first time when
I was doing our pre-seed.
And so when I was like,
look, we're doing our seed,
obviously, I'd built a
relationship with them
over a year.
So then it was easy for
them to say yes, we're in.
So I think that's
how it was different.
It was definitely targeted.
I think probably naivete made
me a bit fearless last time.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah,
fantastic, yeah.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: But also
you do waste a bit of time
in that way.
And if you're doing it
ever, you can be selfish.
Your time is precious, too.
And maybe it's not the right
time to take that introduction.
If someone says to you, amazing.
Wait right now.
I'm just going to introduce you
to-- is it OK to say, actually,
can I come back to you when I'm
ready for that introduction?
Because you don't
want to waste it.
It could be an amazing
intro, but do it
at a time that suits you.
MITRA NATARAJ: So if I go back
a little bit to when you first
launched, so you want
to make a big splash,
but I assume you don't want
a bunch of people downloading
this app and no one
else is on there.
And I was listening to an
interview with a Tinder
founder.
And he was like, he
basically ran from one room
to the other in a college
campus, and was like,
women are there.
And then he ran
to the other room,
and was like, get on there
because men are there.
And he had to kind of get
those first people online
before you could actually
get big traction.
So how did you get those--
that first critical
mass before you
can make a big
splash in the market?
Or is that how you did it?
Or how did you intro it?
No?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: The idea
was we would launch in London
and New York simultaneously.
And we would seed it
with some women who we
knew had existing communities.
Very small, it was
really proof of concept.
Can you go and test it?
Seed it to women that you know.
Get their feedback.
Let's see.
So, really, in
that first week, I
think we thought we'd be
doing really well if we
had 50 people using it, and we
could see their interaction.
And we did do that.
And then the next day,
it went [EXPLOSION NOISE]
And the press coverage was--
MITRA NATARAJ: Insane.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: --insane
and very interested.
And so that amplified.
But I still was very
clear on the fact
that if you're building
a social product,
you have to feel
exactly what you said.
There are people around you.
You can't open the app and
be like, OK, so the nearest
woman is in Tennessee.
MITRA NATARAJ: But you
never had that problem.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Yeah, so--
MITRA NATARAJ: It's so amazing.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: So we
were very focused on it.
But we then became
very reactive.
So we would see women using
it in Dallas or women using it
in LA or women
using it in Chicago.
And then we would do a small
event or a dinner or something
to let other women know in the
area you'll have a great user
experience if you use Peanut
here because we already have
thousands of women using it.
But it was very organic
up until that point.
MITRA NATARAJ: Amazing.
So you sort of
talked about that you
were involved in dating apps.
And Michelle actually
named Bumble.
So you've got a knack
for naming things.
And we've sort of
seeing this arc
that you also described
that online dating was
very weird to begin with.
And now, if you are single and
you do want to meet someone,
it's not a question.
You would be on a dating app.
So what is the arc that you
are trying to see with Peanut?
So my observation--
and you can tell me
if this is right or
wrong-- is that loneliness
is one of the last taboos
that we talk about.
And not just for moms, it's
if you're married or anything,
you have to have this bravado
about not being lonely.
So where do you see--
what is your
overarching mission?
And where do you see
Peanut shaping that arc?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I think
that you're absolutely right.
The evolution from dating going
from something slightly awkward
to everyone's doing it and
my friends describing it
as Michelle in dating, too,
Michelle works in dating, too.
I remember it so clearly.
And I think what there
is a lot of discussion
around is tech and social
media making us more lonely.
And for me, it's all
about how you use it.
If you're using it
in a way that helps
you have those in
real life connections,
how could that ever
be a bad thing?
So we have tools
within Peanut that
facilitate polling and
scheduling times to meet.
So it's like having
a Doodle effectively
but within the messaging.
And three clicks, and
it's in your calendar.
And for me, that
was really important
because it's about
getting that face to face.
But what's more scary?
Sitting looking at your phone
and watching everyone else's
life, or then
sending a connection
to meet someone in real life?
Well, it's more scary just
watching the world pass you.
So I think that
we will see more.
There is a lot more
conversation around loneliness.
And I know that we have a
lot of conversations about,
are millennials the
loneliest generation ever
and all of these things?
And I think that it's about
encouraging tech, or using tech
to help you meet in real life
and to facilitate in real life.
And I think that the last
taboo that we need to break
is actually being able
to come out and say
as a 30-something,
yeah, I'm lonely.
Or, yeah, this is tough, and
it's not everything everyone
told me it would be.
Or, yes, sometimes it's 2 AM.
And I feel like the
whole world is asleep,
and I'm awake feeding this baby.
And no one else understands
me, or whatever it might be.
And that being able to have
that contact with someone
and support, a network
is really important.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah,
do you find that that's
sort of your biggest
barrier to growth,
is that people download
the app, and then they're
nervous about actually
contacting other moms?
And do you see a massive
difference between--
you've launched in
the States, obviously,
and how they've
adopted the product
very differently from here?
MICHELLE KENNEDY:
Yeah, so I think
that there is a difference
between the US and the UK
behavior.
We're only in the US and the UK.
Culturally, I don't know
how terribly British
it is to speak to
people we don't know.
I don't think we're madly good
at it versus in the States
where people are perhaps a
little bit more open to giving
it a go.
And so I do think
that we can see
a little bit of a difference.
Again, it kind of depends on
your stage of life as well.
If you used a dating app to
meet your partner, of course,
this doesn't seem like a hurdle.
Well, of course, it
would be a natural thing
that you're going to use an
app like this to meet friends.
So they're all different.
It's very personal in that way.
I think that we do see women
who use the app and watch.
They're watching.
I'm a lurker, too,
so I totally get it--
so watching before they do it.
And then I sometimes
get messages from women.
What can I say?
I don't know what the
best message to send is,
or whatever it is.
And for me, I'm just
like, say anything.
Say Hi.
Say what you're
eating, whatever.
It doesn't matter.
But that's much less scary.
Sending that
message is much less
scary than spending
a week on your own
without a grown-up to talk to.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah, absolutely.
So I'm going to open it up
to the floor in one question.
So keep them ready.
Before I do that, so
at Google, I mean,
we obviously started out
with two people in a garage.
And one of the principles
that we try to stay true to,
at least, is being very
scrappy and having less
will force you to be
smarter and do better.
So you're obviously small still.
So how are you thinking?
You've got ambitious
plans for Peanut.
But you're still a small team.
So how are you prioritizing?
And how are you thinking about
your next growth stage given
that constraint so that you
propel yourself in the best
way possible to grow?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I
think it's really hard.
I do believe that having little
makes you scrappy because you
have no choice, right?
And it's do or die.
I have to go out
there, and I have
to establish that the
product is, firstly, viable
and, secondly,
we've got traction.
Otherwise we have no product.
So I do believe in it.
We are a team of six.
So we're very small.
And every decision I make,
I equate to head count.
So if I'm going to spend
x on a really nice office,
for example-- and I'm not
currently; I'm squatting.
But if I'm going to
spend x on office space,
well, that's like
two extra people
in the team that can
make us go, reach
that part of our roadmap
three months ahead of plan.
So I always equate it to
headcount and the ability
to go faster.
I cheekily ask for favors.
People have asked me
for favors in the past,
and I've always
helped where I can.
So I don't think anyone should
be shy to ask for favors.
They actually might be really
excited to work with you.
And what's the worst?
They say no.
OK.
So it's no bother.
So I shamelessly ask people.
And I think what
we now need to do,
we're building a new feature
at the moment which is very
head-down, product focused.
And then we really have
to go out and amplify it.
And that's quite scary
because I have to go and let
all of our existing users know.
Fine-- that's no bother.
But now it's really
sharing it more widely.
And we have a limited budget.
And we have a certain
time to establish it in.
And we'll have to
learn as we go.
And probably because
we are a team of six,
we can be quite
agile and say, OK,
that didn't work, scrap, next.
We do a bit of test and dump.
Test it-- didn't work.
OK, next.
And I think not being
precious and not
being too tied to your
idea of this will work,
and being prepared to say,
OK, and on with the next
is helpful.
But I've made mistakes
along the way.
Of course, we all do.
At the time, it's the most
painful thing in the world.
You're like, oh, my god.
That was 5,000 pounds.
And then it's 5K that I
will never waste again.
MITRA NATARAJ: Absolutely.
So I'm going to open
it to the floor.
Anyone with questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: OK, sorry.
Quick question-- two
quick questions for you.
One, co-founders are
really important because
after your seed funding,
for all other rounds,
that duo is really
important to investors.
So how did you pick
your co-founder?
And the second
question is, did you
find what you were
looking for out of Peanut?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: So Greg
is my perfect opposite.
He is brilliant.
Not that I'm not
brilliant-- sounds awful.
Confidence, Michelle.
But he's very focused.
And he is a
brilliant technician.
And he is very logical.
And I'm always
thinking of over here,
and he's thinking about how
we're going to get there.
I found Greg purely by accident.
I was speaking to a friend
that we had in common
and saying that I
really needed to hire,
but I couldn't hire anyone
from Badoo or Bumble.
I was under a
restrictive covenant.
And so my usual pool
was out of bounds.
And she said, oh, you
should speak to Greg.
He's just left Deliveroo.
He'll have an idea
of the market.
And so I was waiting
for the introduction.
I got really impatient.
It was taking a long time.
So I just e-mailed him.
And I was like, so I'm
waiting for this introduction
from our friend.
Can I pick your brains about
the market and whatever?
And we started speaking.
And he was like,
actually, I love the idea.
I'm going to do with you.
So it was-- we kind fell
into it in that way.
He has a little girl and
had understood the issues
surrounding it.
And so I was very
lucky in that way.
And he's definitely probably
the better half of Peanut.
And in terms of have I go
out of Peanut what I wanted,
it is the best feeling
in the world when
someone messages you
to say, I've just met
my ex-best friend on Peanut.
Or, I was having a
really tough time,
and I can see light at
the end of the tunnel
because I've got a
drink with a girl
I've met on Friday, whatever
it might be because that's
what it's for, right?
And my favorite thing--
it's like a weird--
get off a plane wherever I am,
open Peanut, see women around.
Hi.
Speak to them.
[INAUDIBLE] just to
see what they're doing.
And it's amazing.
I can find out
where they go to eat
or where's a kid-friendly
place, whatever it is.
And it's that kind of
community and hyper community.
It's amazing.
So, yeah, I'm very proud of it.
AUDIENCE: My name is Camilla.
And I'm super excited
to have you here.
So the question is,
you're being a lawyer,
I'm assuming you did have some
exposure to technical terms
and stuff in your
previous careers.
But still, building an
app is very technical.
So, how did you overcome?
How deep was your knowledge,
did it have to be?
Or you probably had your
co-founder to help with that.
Basically, the fear is,
can you actually learn
all these things?
Or do you have to as a founder?
MITRA NATARAJ: And we--
I think most of the
people in this building
are on the business side.
And so when we
talk to engineers,
there is a little
bit of a disconnect.
So the extension of
that is, how do you
make your preferences known
so that they interpret it
into what is now
really a beautiful app?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I just
ask questions all the time.
And I don't think I really
have a shame about whether it's
a stupid question or not because
it would be most stupid if I
pretended to know and
it turns out wrong
or I haven't been able to
express it in the right way.
I am very fortunate
Greg is patient.
And I do have a brilliant team
who I communicate well with.
And you're right.
I was working in an industry
where I have an awareness.
But I will ask.
And I will pick and
prod until I understand
why we can't do something or
why it's been done in that way.
And I just think
that you have to be
fearless in the questions.
Actually, you'll
find in the same way
that you feel proud about
your work every day,
the engineers are so
proud of what they do,
if you ask, they're delighted
to share it with you, right?
Everyone in my team, if
I want to know something,
they're delighted to
tell me why it is.
And I suppose if you
were so interested
and you both care about
what you're building,
it's natural that you will
ask and they will answer.
And you'll get to that point.
But I don't think
you should ever
be fearful of what you ask.
MITRA NATARAJ: I think
there's a question here.
AUDIENCE: Two things.
The first one is, because
in a social network,
you have that effect that
the more people you have,
blah, blah, blah.
I want to ask you
about how you picked up
the very initial people to seed
it with because it influences
the trajectory.
The second thing I want
to ask is about funding.
So where did you go
for funding and why?
Since you have a UK
and a US connection,
I think that there are things
that fly here and don't
fly over there, and
vice versa, if you
have an opinion about it.
MICHELLE KENNEDY:
And so in terms
of getting those initial
users, in getting
that initial
traction, that really
comes down to me just
speaking to a lot of people
and being cheeky
enough to say, so I've
got this app coming out.
Can I let you know when it's
like-- will you test it for me?
And mostly people
want to be involved,
and they want to
help you, and they
want to test something new.
So, again, shamelessly asking
people, will you do that?
Will you send it-- will you
share it with your friends?
Will you tell your
friends when it's ready?
And using my friends in the
States, in New York, to say,
hey, can you ask
your girlfriends?
So it was really that.
And I think that the more
you talk about something--
I've had people
say weird things.
You mustn't tell
anyone your idea.
Don't tell anyone your
idea until it's ready.
I just think it's
bizarre because how will
you ever know whether your idea
is for you or for everyone?
You'll never know whether your
product has a good fit or not.
So I spoke-- well, [INAUDIBLE]
and I spoke at a wedding--
I spoke to everyone about it
because I wanted to know more.
And I wanted to know what
people had to say about it.
And I wanted to understand
how they would use it and why
so that then when
it came to release,
they were excited
to test it for me.
I tested it.
I had a group of girlfriends
who I was testing colors with.
Do you like this
color or this color?
logo or this logo?
Would you press this
button or this button?
I mean, it was really like that.
So I think if you are
doing something social,
you have to find that
pool of people who you
want to test it with and test.
And in today's kind
of environment,
you can create that
group anywhere.
You can create it
in a Facebook group
or on Twitter gather people, or
get some people on an Instagram
handle and get them to
follow you and then--
there are so many
ways that you can
test, like get a social
group and test it
before you have to
get to the stage
where you're going to build an
app or whatever it might be.
In terms of funding and
getting the right funders,
as I mentioned before, I have
got the most brilliant funders.
And I'm so super proud
of all of my funders.
And they all bring
something different.
There's all a different angle.
I have some who are US
and some who are UK.
So I don't have
predominantly US or UK.
I have a bit of a split.
I say UK.
I mean Europe, actually.
So I have a bit of a split.
And I think that
when finding funders,
it's really about finding
the right people who
understand your business.
And really this time
around, I researched
so that I knew exactly
what businesses they'd
invested in before,
whether they were
analogous to what I was trying
to do or whatever it might be.
So it's pretty dispiriting
thing when you speak to people
and they're like,
moms don't need that.
They drink coffee all day.
Or, better not
show my wife that.
She spends enough
time on her phone
or whatever other
nonsense stuff.
And I've heard it all.
And then you hear--
you meet someone, and
they're brilliant.
And they say, OK, so what's
the size of the market?
OK, so why is what
you're doing different?
OK, so how are you
going to monetize?
OK, so where do you think
the barrier to entry is?
And all of those smart
questions because they're not
seeing it as you, as a woman
who happens to be a mother
and creating a mothering app.
They're seeing it as a business
and a market potential.
And it's finding those gems.
And they are there.
And I think that at
the moment, there's
a lot of bad press around
the funding and VCs.
And that's probably deserved
for those who deserve it.
But there are some brilliant,
brilliant minds out there.
And it's just about
finding them and being
relentless in your search to
find the right partner for you.
AUDIENCE: And you found
funding pre-revenue?
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Yes.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MICHELLE KENNEDY:
Pre-product, actually.
AUDIENCE: Pre-product?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So what's
changed for you
now that you run your
own business versus being
CEO of someone else's business?
MICHELLE KENNEDY:
It's like did you ever
used have that dream when you
go into school and you're naked,
and everyone's laughing
and you don't know why,
and then you look
down and you're naked?
It's like that dream every day.
It was like that at the start.
It's very scary.
There is strength in numbers.
And when I was at
Badoo, I really
felt like I was part
of something huge,
a small part of something huge.
but there was that safety.
And when you're doing it on
your own, it's all on you.
And it's really scary.
And it's personal because
I always cared about my job
and it was a huge
part of my identity,
but I care so much
about Peanut because I
don't want to let my team
down, my investors down,
my users down, women down.
There's so many huge
pressures that I just
don't want to let that fall.
And so there is a huge
burden of responsibility.
Similarly, I feel that the
highs are extraordinarily
high because you know every
single ounce of when you moved
that tiny, tiny icon 0.2
millimeters to the left,
and you know that there was a
real thought process behind it,
and all of a sudden your
conversion increases.
And you're like, ah!
And no one else knows that, but
the high is so high from that
that it makes it all worthwhile.
But it's extraordinarily
hard work and--
which it was before, but
it's a different kind
of work and pressure, I think.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
I have a few questions.
So one is how did
you get your roadmap?
And in terms of company growth,
what do you see in the future?
And how do you realign
that when things change?
My second question is, I
guess, having a startup
and being so
passionate about it,
and having a successful career
that you've had, how do you--
you almost become consumed
by your idea because--
and it's good to be because
you're so passionate,
but how do you
find-- keep yourself
sane in terms of working hours?
How do you do that?
I think that is one
of my main questions.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Pause,
otherwise I'll forget them.
What was the first one?
Tell me the first one again.
AUDIENCE: It was about--
MITRA NATARAJ: It was
about the road map.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Oh,
the road map, yeah.
So, the road map was--
I suppose it was like this
very broad vision of Peanut
has to be like
modern motherhood.
And that's what we
want it to represent.
And here are all the
facets of modern motherhood
that we could cover.
OK, I don't want that.
We don't need to be that.
Someone else is doing that.
And really kind of boiling
it down in that way.
And then thinking
very specifically
about where we really felt
like that the opportunity lay
and how we can kind of unpick
it and get through that.
And I would say that the
road map is ever evolving.
And sometimes we have an idea.
And we all love it.
But we know it's not priority.
And it shuffled to the back.
And it's that sad kind
of item [INAUDIBLE]
that will maybe never
come to the forefront.
And we hope it will, but
probably won't until we
double in size.
And sometimes it is imperative
that we deal with something
because it's impacting on
the way users are interacting
with the product.
So I think it's just being
on your toes all the time
and not being wedded to it so
that you're prepared to change.
And we have an idea for our
subsequent feature the one
we have.
But it might change.
We have to wait and see how
users use our next feature
first before we
can really say, OK,
is that going to be
the right direction?
Or maybe we'll discover
something brand new.
So I think a lot of it comes
from watching user behavior
as well and your
analytics, and really
being so grateful for
the amazing data where
you can watch the behaviors.
Balance-- some work-life
balance doesn't exist, just
in case anyone's interested.
It's a lie.
I think it's a juggle.
And some days you're
amazing at juggling things.
terrible at juggling things.
And some days you're
an amazing partner.
And sometimes you're
a horrible partner.
an amazing boss.
And sometimes you're the worst.
And you just have to be
a little bit at peace,
and you kind juggle it.
But if you're going to do
something that you love,
you have to be a bit
obsessed by it, I think.
Literally all of my friends
and family are Peanut-obsessed.
It's all I can talk about.
And I think you have to
be like that because it's
what makes you get up
and out of bed at 6 AM
to do some work before my
little boy gets up to get ready.
It's the drive.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to--
I guess, there's a problem that
you thought, I can fix this.
To me, it seems like the big
difference in entrepreneurship
today compared to, say, 30 years
ago is the need to monetize
and where that comes in.
So I just wondered
when you started
thinking about
that and more what
pressure you got from
funds about how developed
your thinking had to be.
MICHELLE KENNEDY:
Yeah, there was
an amazing deck for the
LinkedIn series B raise.
I think it's on the
Greylock web site.
Anyway, if you
haven't read it, you
should go and have a look
at it because it's amazing
because it's actually
a critique by one
of the co-founders
of his own deck,
as like looking at it from
a VC perspective having
been the entrepreneur.
And in that, he identifies
three lines of possible revenue.
And his critique is you
shouldn't be talking
about three lines of revenue.
You should really only
be talking about one.
But we didn't really know.
So it's really interesting
to see his own critique
of his own work effectively.
And its also--
I mean, read it,
anyway, because it's
really fascinating to see what
their predicting growth was,
where they were.
And you forget--
I think we forget
how-- not how slow,
but it was an
incremental growth.
It wasn't all of a sudden
just bang, LinkedIn.
It took time.
So, obviously, I had thoughts
and ideas on monetization.
I've come from a world where
Badoo monetizes extremely well.
And so I had ideas.
I think probably my
main stress point--
and, I think, it's
specific to my market--
is everyone assumes I
want to do advertising.
It's women an moms advertising.
Is that you're model?
No.
It's that.
So for me it was
more about, here
are some other possible streams.
I don't know which ones
are right because I need
to see how people are
engaging with the product
before I can definitively
say, but here are some ideas.
I know not all of them
revolve around an app model.
But I think having
some smart thought
around how you could
see it progressing,
even if it doesn't
end up going that way,
but to show that you've given it
consideration, is a good idea.
But LinkedIn started with
three streams on their deck.
It was good enough for them.
MITRA NATARAJ: I think we have
time for one more question.
Yeah?
OK.
Go.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So by the time you launched,
[INAUDIBLE] just launched,
I was wondering how you
handled that in your investor
presentations, and if
that was a pushback
from potential investors at all.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I think that
anyone who is doing something
in the same space as you
or the same market as you,
it is confidence that
there is a market.
And all it does--
there isn't just one dating app.
There isn't just one
type of cola drink.
There is probably just
one search engine.
MITRA NATARAJ: No.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: But
I think all of those,
having the ability to have
someone else in the market,
just establishes a proof and
a validity in the market.
And I think that's important.
I think that what will be
your differentiators, how
you execute, how you see the
market evolving, how you see
your product devolving, how
do you see differentiators,
and for me, there are just
lots of different ways
to solve the same problem.
And it's all about how
you're answering that problem
and why you're with
the right person
to solve the problem in
the way that you see it
because everyone will
take a different approach.
So in terms of how I responded
to it didn't really--
AUDIENCE: Fair enough.
MICHELLE KENNEDY: I was
very single-minded in what
we were doing.
MITRA NATARAJ: Yeah, absolutely.
I think we've run out of time.
So I'm going to thank Michelle--
MICHELLE KENNEDY: Thank you.
MITRA NATARAJ: --for joining us.
It was amazing.
Thank you so much for coming in.
And let's give her
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]